l'implication présumée de la france dans
la guerre au yémen est souvent pointée
du doigt par des ong voire même par
l'onu qui a épinglé en septembre dernier
le soutien logistique de certains pays
dont la france à la coalition qui mène
la guerre contre les outils au yémen ces
nouvelles révélations d'amnesty
international risquent de renforcer ces
accusations après plusieurs mois
d'enquêté les ong publie des
informations sur la création d'un centre
d'entraînement dans la commune de
commercy dans la meuse un campus
implanté sur une ancienne base militaire
et qui appartient au groupe belge s'est
mis l'objectif recevoir et former les
clients de l'entreprise en l'occurrence
des militaires saoudiens pour apprendre
la manipulation de tourelles canon
cockerill au programme instructions des
tireurs des pilotes et des mécaniciens
au maniement de sa tourelle et de son
système d'armes d'une capacité de 120
stagiaires le campus cockerill doit
accueillir ses soldats à partir de 2017
et pour sept ans - une formation censée
s'étaler chaque année sur six à neuf
mois dans la paisible campagne française
hôtels restaurants sauna et mosquées
pour créer une sorte de bulle tout a été
pensé pour placer les militaires
saoudiens dans les meilleures conditions
il est très difficile de savoir si le
campus en a déjà accueilli
écoutez ce qu'en dit audrey lebel
l'auteur de l'article
en off on me dit qu'il y en a qu il y en
a même qui aurait été coincés là bas
pendant toute la crise du coc vide mais
officiellement même les élus locaux
disent ne pas savoir si les formations
ont véritablement commencé à commercy si
la présence des soldats saoudiens n'est
pas confirmé l'existence même de ce
campus et de ce programme d'entraînement
font débat car au delà de la situation
géopolitique
ce projet a bénéficié d'argent public
notamment par le biais des aides
accordées par le conseil régional de
lorraine
six cent mille euros avait ainsi été
débloqués en 2015 provoquant de vives
réactions notamment de jacqueline
fontaine qui était à l'époque
conseillère régionale e élevé il y a un
grand décalage entre la présentation
bien pudique du dossier et la réalité du
projet on apprend à faire la guerre à
des saoudiens
on n'est pas sûr qu'on les retrouvera
pas un jour face à nous sur un terrain
quelconque
surtout que pour justifier un tel
investissement les retombées économiques
étaient mises en avant retombées dont
les habitants peinent à voir les fruits
encore aujourd'hui plus globalement
cette base d'entraînement pose la
question du soutien de la france à la
coalition saoudiennes et émiraties au
yémen
la secrétaire d'état aux armes et
geneviève darrieussecq s'est d'ailleurs
rendu sur le campus de commercy en avril
bien que sous pavillon privé ce centre
semble finalement s'inscrire dans une
volonté exprimée en 2015 par le quai
d'orsay de vouloir encourager je cite
l'augmentation de la coopération sur le
terrain des exercices militaires et de
l'entraînement en arabie saoudite et en
france depuis le monde a pu constater
l'horreur humanitaire créée par cette
guerre au yémen et l'indignation de
l'opinion publique suscite un certain
embarras parmi les gouvernants des pays
exportateurs d'armes en arabie saoudite
cette base d'entraînement sur le sol
français pourrait là encore être une
épine dans le pied du ministère des
armées et a fortiori pour le président
de la république